blattmann giorno 3 mancano 21 giorni
alla vigilia
e ancora o le decorazioni di halloween
credo che se reato il momento è arrivato
il momento di fare il castello di
reporter che effettivamente diciamo che
è anche un po una sorta di presepe cioè
non fa il per esempio però il castello
io preparo intanto il tavolo perché
stanno arrivando al mio fratello enrico
e gianmarco buon salve vela con salver
ti sei fatta [ __ ] per questo costruttore
ragazze e tantissima roba un'emozione ma
non si fanno non hai capito dobbiamo
farcela che cosa c'è là dentro anzi di
ieri tra muffin salati brown e non mi
ricordo le altre cinque ragazzi mia
cugina fate i dolci pazzesche ma massimo
si può dire se pasticcera apprendista
pasticcera ragazzi buoni ed è tutto
buonissimo quello che fa sotto
buonissima cita gli avanzi lei io non è
che ci dà le cose ci dagli avanzi che
cosa sono
un cartello che cosa di fare caccia che
deve arrampicare la soprano eva bene lo
mettevo che lo pensando nessuna partenza
cucinavo sta vicino esplosa intanto
tutti permettere di dire che illogica la
disposizione dammi la prendiamo un
tratto però quando vogliamo questo aiuta
lasciati perché stanchi ma doni cardella
cosa più buona che a chi immagina forse
l'unica cosa che mangerò per i prossimi
sei mesi a casa ben sette verde offre
essi è molto fico lui e invece lui e
abbiamo letto elga edgar ed gara per
l'udc ha rapito poi un pazzesco sana
serie bones al azhar ha una testa perché
è pazzesca rouen
come si sa l'italia non chi priscilla
corvonero tanta tanta tanta rico
vorrebbe assaggiare un pezzo di questa
cosa qui che non riesco a inquadrare ci
mettono davanti come fanno con i trucchi
le beauty blogger è presente mette una
mano e aprì a mano ecco aspetta un
secondo che cerco di inquadrarla lo
fanno non funziona questo gruppo
funziona coi pennelli ma non credo il
coro col cibo ai cani da enrico se dai
un morso il mio stesso morso potrei
assaggiarlo
preferisce morire di fame è una quiche
lorraine buonissima con cipolle da
dietro da dietro ma non ti sei portato
le tue posate da scout c'è anche il
platano picchiatore ha detto fatto
enrico rigo sta costruendo
vabbè basta così in quanto l energia lo
ha fatto notare che finito il calendario
dell'avvento due dice ti odio
no va bene
iniziamo a girare fondi solo per chi
lavora avvertito ragazzi è un botto
dell'ammontare ma che stai scazzi sono
quattro libri per multarlo e noi che
cosa facciamo noi costruiremo forza come
facciamo a dominare paramenti capitolo
ragazzi non finiremo mai è già
particelle il 3 a un certo punto si
aggiunge a questo che per ammontato a
parte che è montato a parte ma poi
cominci a interagire e aggiungere roll
bar per costruire ancora di più esatta e
poi tutto va assemblato però può cioè
possiamo legame ha le gambe di carmen ha
poi questo sì ma lasciamo segrete che
cambiano iniziamo a questo se mette così
mi chiamano a mettere le strutture
storica ed è vostro non è nostro e noi
siamo organizzati con una squadra di
toronto canada
ho progettato inizialmente di questi si
sarebbe sentito tutta una cosa sbagliata
questa qui ti aiuta a togliere analizza
dal balletto facciamo che ve la vedete
voi quella tasto rosso
questo può essere sa cosa può essere un
segreto gli leggo.it attività prova a
ripeterlo che cosa in quello che ha
appena detto che montare le guin
famiglia è la cosa più importante
li odio tutti hanno così a 1 sono
totalmente spaesati dami cristallina non
sanno dove mettere le mani
di certo però fare tutti la stessa cosa
veramente noi siamo bloccati
ci prova perché lo purtroppo il nostro
progetto richiede il loro progetto ma
stiamo aspettando da ore la che falso
ipocrita zitta priscilla carbone nel
sangue
sento l'odore di summer posso dire che
c'è in tutto questo tempo aver fatto
quattro ball combinano accusate cinque
barche prendi quello di quell'altro e
questo tipo e scusate rigirarlo e così
mi rimetto no insomma enrico ragazzi vi
spiego subito una cosa quando c'è questo
simbolo è vuol dire dovete girare la
costruzione che girano per adesso si
cambia di roraima state issate cosa
davvero il delle barchette ci avete
costruito un personaggio che dovevi
montato pezzi allora gianmarco che fa lo
scienziato insomma quell'altro dice
fotografiamo le le istruzioni così ci
portiamo avanti
ecco la foto che hanno fatto mossa
alborno para terzine di niente prego
sette anni segreti senza le scale
basilisco senza testa ma se andiamo
veloci datemi mani gli rubiamo la camera
dei segreti
ragazzi per sentite di pensare questo
basti a quando si accende la telecamera
loro sembrano superfici supporto si
spegne la telecamere e sono in crisi
e allora queste sono le foto che ci ha
fatto guglielmo parla tanto di di
precisione è ti salva la camera che non
ammette a fuoco a no è proprio cosi la
foto non si vede niente
c'è miss top questo diventando c'è una
furia di vedere la come si dice in
questi casi
chrome os ma perde tu vuoi trovare il
punto al taqwa questa roba qui manca
questa è posso dire che noi non abbiamo
mai visto quella roba lì non vedo un
colpevole io lo vedo un altro madonna
come avete moderate che cosa poi
ripetere un confronto così perché sennò
siamo una bari e qui c'è un errore di
base c'è poco da fare
mentre continua che cerchiamo di non osa
commerciamo provando a risolvere il
problema da voi ballate basta da
mezzosangue
e sempre stato da me è tutto rientrato
il tubo prezzo stiamo sobbarcando
abbiamo messo questa struttura sopra ea
questo punto ancora non parla non so
quanti ne abbia hogwarts ma stiamo
facendo il primo piano vai soppalcato
parliamo di judo a far calcio al
soppalco dai fammi soppalcare va bene
fare un cammino
ognuno dovrebbe mettere una pietra ogni
membro del clan ma giusto buonismo marco
e azione ovviamente l'avevamo già fatto
prima
[Risate]
abbiamo dovuto rifarlo rifarlo come se
non l'avessi visto vai così vai con dio
ammazza dio
[Musica]
china tutto questo ma andando avanti
hanno perso il senso del tempo e dello
spazio
con questa vetrata ma in tutto questo
sviluppo urbano giulia io giulia tu hai
fatto partire questo fatto no no no no
incominciamo a dirlo incominciamo dello
stava iniziando a perdere il senno
sono ore che lavoriamo io continuo
giammarco di cosa è sbagliato
questo non usato i quadratini bianchi di
rimuovere tutto dai diciamo che sì sì
esattamente
continuiamo non siamo o non siamo
nemmeno a metà dei maya ok fatto po per
creare le scale alle strade piace
cambiare
è passato dopo un ora dall ultimo
aggiornamento per dire che stiamo
andando avanti ma ti pare
il segno è anche il tutto andato cioè
lei sta facendo schizzare pezzi in giro
loro loro sembra che stiamo costruendo
un non lo so un'astronave il castello
cresce molto cresce molto meno
riusciremo a finirlo entro stasera
perché siamo alla fine del secondo
manuale di istruzioni e ne abbiamo altri
due ancora e tutta quella roba lì da
montare tutta quella roba lì e mentre
loro perdono tempo a perdere una visita
storica molti il team aqua tutto questo
ha creato lo spuntino il tema
loro hanno fatto quello queste sono per
ingegneristiche non quello ma che cos'è
quella roba male in peggio
giulia ormai tre anni con troisi attacca
più ne va così così sembra proprio di
vino con quella luce dietro è che
dissennatori wow
veramente non in realtà gara finita
posso dire che cosa mi ricorda un po qua
vabbè ma colore mangiata heroes uscì
infatti mente che era mangiato la pasta
allora fa non erano scesi i primati a
casa da solo dio come tavernier nel
castello di hogwarts ma c'è dop il
personaggio noi adesso ci sentiamo
domani ore 9 qui
[Risate]
noi naturalmente ci vediamo sempre
domani alle 14 con il blog mas e la
magia del natale